about a year ago
we started building a new project uh
which is now in public beta it's called
cloudera search and uh
morph lands is really a spin-off from uh
from that project you know it came out
of cloudera search
something that you know was directly
useful for us but we're not also making
it available to a broader audience
because it's uh it's more applicable you
know
beyond the boundaries of just uh search
and so i'm going to talk a lot about
about that and how and use search as a
use case as a motivating use case to
illustrate
some of the example applications
so we'll talk about big data and etl and
search how it all fits together and then
dive into what the
you know fundamental elements of the
architecture of
morph lands are and talk about some of
the aspects
in more detail and take a dive and then
see how the technology can be applied to
example use cases and i'll
oftentimes you know uh use cloudera
search because that's what i'm most
familiar with
but uh part of the reason why i'm here
is because i want to
to learn and know what you guys
would like to do with it and where else
we could take this technology beyond
search
so uh here's a motivating example etl
use case
um that is centered around search we
have a bunch of information coming in
through some that's generated by some
online
systems you know like websites you know
trading or e-commerce sites
uh what have you and it comes in through
um
and basically like a large-scale
ingestion bus
called flume and it's being indexed in
to a system called
uh solar cloud apache solar cloud and
there is essentially raw data streaming
into the system
the way it's being captured say like by
an e-commerce site which is not
necessarily in the right shape
for consumption by a search server so
what happens in the process then is that
this data needs to be massaged
for into a data model that actually
represents this
you know that the search application or
the what the
clients want to do with uh with a search
application
and so we have an etl flow that you know
transforms the data
from from its raw form from potentially
it's very
unclean form into something that is
directly applicable to a search
server we also have at least in our
context
you know large oltp databases like hbase
that are feeding into search servers and
again these
databases contain you know like you know
all sorts of different
kinds of information with all sorts of
different kinds of schemas
and they were built for applications
that
don't necessarily have search in mind
but you also
want to make that information searchable
so again there's a step there to
transform that data to actually make it
useful
for a search application and that etl
that
extract transform and load step is what
we're going to talk about
some more in detail further on
the flume etl flow is essentially a near
real-time indexing flow where data comes
in online
from some sources it needs to be indexed
and be available right away
in hbase similar oftentimes people want
you know whenever there are updates
inserts updates and deletes in hbase
you want to have that information being
reflected
right away or close the right away into
a search index
but then there are also you know more
larger
applications where you run giant
batch jobs to generate search indexes
from existing information in hdfs in the
hadoop storage system
you know potentially index your entire
storage system
say like you know 10 petabytes of data
or something like this using mapreduce
jobs
and again the information is stored in
files and whatever
you know gazillion of different file
formats because you'll end of different
you know ways you're not not necessarily
you know ready for consumption by a
search index
and typically it's raw data
and so it needs to be transformed and
that's the function of atetl
in that flow what you see is that
there's
multiple paths there's multiple
cases where we need an etl component and
there's not just a single
one that a single path or a single flow
or a single system that needs to do etl
but
many of them so from this we can
sort of like infer that it might be
useful to make a
more generally applicable facility that
can be reused
for all these cases rather than reinvent
something new for
for each of them and so we came up with
this idea
for cloudera morph lines which basically
embodies this concept that we have this
reusable etl system that we can embed
and plug into various systems
such as near real-time indexing
or for hbase indexing or from rapid
use-based indexing
or for transferring say relational data
into hadoop and back
using transformation transformation
transformations in the middle
and so forth and so forth so really this
is like a generalization
of what we needed for for
for search and so the idea is that you
can plug it into
other applications uh as well and
whatever whatever whatever you have and
take it beyond the search use case
one of the requirements if you do that
is that
whatever that library does it needs to
be able to deal with a multitude of
different input formats and a multitude
of different
data types it can't just be confined to
say like sql data
or say like xml data or data format x
y or z it needs to sort of be able to
to process you know a variety of
heterogeneous data formats and
make sense uh out of whatever data data
is being thrown at it
so cloudera morph lands then is
an open source framework that we
recently made available
uh under an apache license and it does
simple etl not necessarily you know
anything that uh that can do you know
what
like you know real uh production you
know
uh enterprise etl tools like informatica
or syncsort or pentaho or so so do
it's not a competition you know for you
know commercial
enterprise tools it's just a a library
really at this stage
but it's incredibly useful for our
purposes and uh i believe it's also
useful for you know in other contexts
and so it is designed to
not just for badge applications but also
for near real-time applications
for for these different contexts
and we are making it available
in the form of packaged up in the form
as a
as a as a library inside of the cloudera
development kit
which is a recent effort that we started
about
like half a year ago and so as part of
that
you can you know get more lines outside
of the context of search
you can also get morph lines of
obviously
pre-packaged you know when you get
cloudera search
but that's a different topic
and the the idea is yes please
what was that
as part of cloudera search we package
things up you know for
a variety of different operating systems
you know including debian and suse and
red hat and
centos and i mean but
as part of the cdk we really just
produced maven modules
so you know as far as the cda cdk
concerned
is concerned you know it's just made
even modules but
as part of cloudera search we package it
up um
you know in a you know in a more
in a more uh you know like
considerable consumable way
it would work on any distribution of
hadoop
does it work with any distribution of
yes it does work with any distribution
of hadoop indeed it doesn't actually
have any dependency
on hadoop itself
so you could use it in you know
your email application or
if that makes sense yeah
from a conceptual perspective you know
it reuses some
tried and true you know ideas most
notably
the ones coming from unix pipelines you
know the idea that you have like
little programs or little plugins or
little things that you
plug together and you know that do
transform transformation on a data
stream and then
you know hand that data stream to the
next plugin which does something with it
and hands it off to the next plugin and
does something with it
and so we took that notion a little bit
further
and made it more convenient for the
purpose of like
etl flows and we also made it more more
more efficient
and it becomes it comes
packaged uh already with a variety of
plugins that do useful things out of the
box
and then you can add you know additional
plugins that do
you know things that aren't provided or
that you want to do differently
and so for example there's support for
uh
log files and hadoop you know one of the
extremely common use cases is to just
dump whatever
log files can be available out of high
volume
you know uh websites and production
applications and just dump it all into
hdfs
uh in raw form which is kind of like you
know log files
and then you know you can derive useful
information from it later
and so but by and large you have like
you know humongous amounts of log files
and pretty much unprocessed form
and so that's an extremely uh common use
case dealing with
log files in you know very varied
in various degrees of structured or
unstructured
manner you know then there's also
support for avro
which is a hierarchical you know data
format you know very similar to thrift
or
protobufs uh something that
is very often used in hadoop's ecosystem
and then also for legacy reasons for for
sequence files which is kind of like the
precursor for
of the avro data format and then there's
also
support for data formats that aren't
used as widely
in the hadoop ecosystem like json and
xml and
html and you know things like that
and you know the idea is that we you
know we can never
and we do not want to provide you know
some exhausting
exhaustive functionality but you know
it's the system is designed so you can
easily plug in
whatever you know whatever else makes
sense for you and whatever else you need
so that's probably in the long run
uh even more important than providing
these things out of the box it's nice to
have things out of the box to
you know have some critical threshold
for doing something useful
but in the long run what's actually more
important is that people can
plug in whatever they want and integrate
their own stuff
you know it's much more important in the
long run i believe
and so it would make that easy
so here's a you know a simple example
you have a syslog file with syslog
records coming into the system in this
case
it's a flume agent uh sort of like a
large scale
streaming ingestion system and
that agent runs uh what is called a
solar
sync now some kind of some kind of
a plugin that executes a morph line and
a
morph line really is just a set of
commands
set of processing elements a set of like
you know so like you know like you'd say
like
you know um
filters if you like and so it runs
you know whatever input in the form of
uh events or records through a set of
commands
which transform the record on the way or
can also generate multiple output
records
for each input record in this case it
first
reads one line out of the file and then
out of that syslog log line plugs out
a bunch of substrings you know like say
like you know the
the time and the process id and the log
message itself and who produced it and
things like that
and uh puts it into record fields so
then the information is a little bit
more structured
than it was at the beginning where it's
just was just like a string effectively
and then there's another command that it
runs it through which then loads
the data in into solar and you know if
you
strike out load solo there you could say
like you know yeah maybe you want to
load it up into hbase or maybe you want
to dump it into an hdfs follower
maybe you want to load it up into some
online dashboards or you know what have
you you know
so
so that's the overall idea and
so the more vlans part is like these set
of commands
that are tied tied together and
run over input data and whether that
input data is
a binary file or whether that input data
is already a structured record
you know it will work for for all of
these use cases
and the idea then is we can take these
components these commands and use them
in multiple multiple contexts
so you can use them in different etl
applications
and you can reuse these components so
that you don't have to
you know reinvent the wheel every time
um i already mentioned you know it's
heavily leaning on the unix
pipeline metaphor
and we
we decidedly did not want to build a
system that can stand on its own feet
that is like a standalone server or
something like this but rather we built
a library that can be embedded
into into other stuff you know and we
want to
because we know that we ourselves we
want to embed it into a lot of different
systems
so it did not make sense for us to
actually you know build one server then
it's very specific
for some purpose but rather we want to
embed it in multiple systems
and so what comes to mind is like not
just flume
and mapreduce we have already done that
part but also peak and hive and scoop
so uh pig is a and hive are tools
high level tools that uh let you allow
allow you to express sql queries or
something that closely resembles sql and
run it over
data that's stored that's stored in hdfs
and
run batch jobs uh with something that
closely resembles what a lot of people
are already used to
sql scoop is a tool to import and export
data at scale from and to relational
databases or enterprise
databar warehouses and connect hadoop
to these legacy systems and
and so forth
doesn't support dbz but time it probably
does but i'd have to go and check
it basically picks up you know whatever
comes with the
apache commons compress library and i
believe that also
includes bc support and so
for instance like if you're doing
something like
um
so there is uh there's a command
called decompress that does that
and so it will look at what the file
format
is and whether it's a gzip file or
whether it's a bzip file and
i have to go back with the visa is
decidedly supported or whether we
whether that still needs to be added and
some compression format
and it will just basically unwrap you
know that compression format and then
spit out the
decompressed stream of data so if this
so decompress would be one command
in the pipe there and take this input
like a
compressed stream and today actually
it's like
yeah it's probably already part of that
package you know
uh but you
what you still would need to do is we
have facilities for this is to detect
what kind of file type it is is it a bc
file or is it the gzip file or is it a
what not file
and we have a command for that
specifically geared towards use cases
like this
called detect mime type and it does you
know a similar thing that web browsers
do too when they
get you know arbitrary stuff over http
it sniffs the first couple of bytes
or it looks at file names and metadata
data
headers you know and from that you can
determine what's the file type
and then depending on that file type you
can fill in the
you can fill in that information into a
header and then
the next command you know down the chain
down the chain can look at that
information and then say like okay i'm
gonna
decompress it with easy or i can i'm
going to decompress it with
gzip or i'm just going to let it through
unchanged or whatever
so it's got this notion of mime types
and how to detect mime types
and then how to act on those mind types
depending on
what it is and and it also has this
notion of
recursively unnesting container formats
such as compression formats where you
start out with like you know
it's an arrow file that contains records
which are g-zipped
and that you know and in that side of
that g-shape there's other records with
some other formats
so you can unwrap that you know that
whole nested chain of things to get at
the actual information that's deep down
there
extract that out and fill it into your
record and
load it up into whatever your target
system is
um i already mentioned this you know
it should be easy to plug in things
there's a
there's a class called commands it's got
three methods that
you need to implement if you if you want
to implement a new command and there's
an abstract class that makes it even
easier
you know reduces it like to one method
so it's like a couple of lines of java
code if you want to write your own
command and plug it in and
you don't need to register anything or
like
you know provide some metadata you just
put it on the java class path
and then it becomes available to the
morph line
the data model is a is is very
very flexible it's originally really
taken from the
search domain it's really that we're
dealing with records
and each record has a bunch of fields a
field has a name
it's like a hash table has keys and then
the field also has a list of values
in this case they can be arbitrary java
objects so it's really just basically a
hash table
you know with string keys and with an
array or a list
of java objects as values and that's the
data model that we operate on
it's a directly corresponds one to one
the little scene
and solar uh datum data model it also
corresponds to
i mean any other search server out there
uses precisely the same data model you
know whether it's
google or bing or whatever and and
relational duration data model
is very close to that either you know
usually you know people think of a
relational table as like uh you know
it's just got
one value and a column but you know like
really actual systems you know allow you
to have multi-valued
you know entries in a column as well and
so
it's really a tried and true generic
data model
that fits you know the build for all
sorts of use cases not just
search and when you add in the fact that
the values
aren't just strings or integers but they
can be
java objects meaning like say like a
java input stream
or a binary or you know a json
tree or whatnot and you have a fairly
flexible generic facility that allows
you to
manipulate all sorts of data without
having a
preconception of of what it is that the
application wants to do
how do we pass in binary data there is
as i mentioned a way to deal with
input streams and batteries and so by
convention we have a field called
attachment body similar to say like an
http
you know message or like an email
message we have a field called body
attachment body and you can fill in java
input stream in there that
is basically you know uh representing a
file that you're reading
or maybe it's a binary you know
represents an event from flume for
example
and then you can also have pass
additional optional fields
that are convention names such and such
like mime type you know
or character encoding or
name for for that object that are useful
to certain applications
in detecting you know what kind of data
it is and how to interpret
the data in case there's ambiguity
so then the idea that
we can deal with an arbitrarily large
stream you know really continuous
streams
of data uh not just like uh you know
uh you know the records contained in a
table and then we're done
but rather continuous continuous
continuous
streams of data and each command
transforms its input record receives an
input record
into zero or more output records if you
wanna like a router
you know ignore the piece of information
because it's not applicable you just
drop it you know you
don't return an output record or maybe
you want to transform it
you return one output record or maybe
you know you know
say like an email might actually lead to
multiple output records
or say like a table or a file a csv file
might actually lead to
a gazillion of output records for one
input record every line being one other
record
or maybe you can you want to split
a record into a record field and to
run to multiple disparate fields and
emit a record for each of those
so it's got this this uh zero to n
upper record capacity
and
in simple examples you have this linear
chain of
like a unix pipeline where something
pipes into something else and which
pipes into something else
but really commands can actually have
some nested structure
you know like and combat embed other
commands which can embed other commands
so for more advanced use cases you know
that doesn't
usually doesn't come up initially but
for advanced more advanced use cases
you can really have like this this this
flow that's
through a tree of commands so
it's not unlike you know you know a data
flow engine
where you push information through a
tree of
transformation elements you know so like
the inverse of like
for like a you know an execution plan in
the query engine
and so because the system is explicitly
designed to be embedded into other host
systems
it makes no assumptions about and has no
notion about
persistence or durability or distributed
computing
we're dealing with the we're interested
in expressing
the actual transformations that people
want to do and apply them in
multiple contexts and so basically it's
really just
you know a chain of main memory
transformations
without without notions about
things that host systems already provide
say like
you know failover you know you know
persistence you know uh
you know distributed you know like cues
and things like that
all of that stuff is already provided by
say like flume or by storm
you know or by kafka or by mapreduce and
so there's really no point in
reinventing these things but rather you
know embed
this library into these into the systems
that have their
have their own way of dealing with um
with uh
high availability and reliability
reliability
and so forth
we do however provide facilities to
select past transactional contexts
through commands through that chain of
commands so like when a
transaction starts begins and when
you know when it commits you know when
you roll back a
transaction so there are there are
facilities to pass transactional
concepts
uh transactional estate through which
allows you to say like do efficient
batching in reliable ways
so that that load solar command that i
showed
early on uh does it consumes one record
and then it loads the record up into
solar
but it doesn't do it like one record at
a time it batches it up
in larger batches and then sends a big
batch into solar to be
efficient and if you want to do that in
a transactional context
these things you know coming come in
very handy
to to do that sort of thing reliably
in terms of performance and scaling so
a morph line really is just a
configuration file it's not something
that you
it's not java code that you write
typically even though
you might want to provide your own
plugin but really it's just a
configuration file
it gets compiled by you know the library
on startup
you give it that configuration file and
it does something with it
and then it gets executed and run
executed
at runtime many times in some very
efficient way
why is it efficient because piping
from one command to the other does not
evolve
handing off you know a piece of
information from one thread to another
thread
say like via a queue but rather it's
just a method called it's a java method
called from one object to another object
and has you know minimal effort the
overhead of a java method call
so there's no serialization involved and
deserialization between
a command and a pipe and there's no
context switches
you know one thread screen involved so
it's just
so that's that's something that's um
that's very important you know for
you know high volume big data processing
and the other notion is there that
amorphon
is single threaded you know it's uh
it's running in one it's running all the
commands in the very same
thread and so if you want to have
scalability in the number of you know
in the number of cpus or in the number
of nodes that you have in your system
you just run many of those things you
run many more flights
many clones of the same morph line one
per
cpu core and on many machines so like
you know you
run 10 000 you you know mapper tasks in
your mapreduce job
or maybe you run like 100 plume agents
and each flume agent is running 16 more
lines or something like this you know
uh and they all do the same they all do
the very same
facility but they don't need to
synchronize with each other
you know they're completely independent
in terms of syntax we just adopted
something it was already out there it's
called hokon
it's basically json slightly adjusted to
the configuration file use case
so like in json you can't write comments
it doesn't have no notion of comments
so they added in you know the facility
to write comments in there so like
you can document your configuration file
and make it and
some small little tweaks you know like
it makes it a little bit more amenable
to specify your configuration file
so we just picked it up and it comes out
of typesafe.com
and uh it's a little odd at first maybe
to look at
but uh people get used to it in at least
an hour in our experience
pretty quickly so here's an example
so if you had a log file and it has
stack traces in it
then typically that's a little gnarly
you know that's where like a lot of
systems you know like they
don't really work so well because a
record
really spans multiple lines and you
can't just say like okay we'll take it
like
line by line uh but rather you know a
record spans multiple lines so
how would you like take a log file and
and
process that into records and then load
it up into say like a search server or
into some into hbase or in some smaller
database
uh well it's got moist lens has
one handy command for for this it's
called uh
read multi-line and it basically allows
you to specify a regular expression for
where the record starts and where it
stops and everything in between
you know constitutes a record so that's
one way you know like
how you can you know within a couple of
lines of a configuration file
you can specify okay you know
how to parse that file format and then
how to
load it up say into some target system
so
you also see there is this little
command called log debug that for
debugging purposes you can print out
whatever the
current record state is what the content
of the fields are in the current record
so you can print that out to a logging
facility to sli 4j
you know whenever you want
here's some other example command as i
mentioned before you can write
you can write your own plugins you can
write your own commands in java code
and then make them available and it's
going to take you like you know whatever
20 lines of java code or something like
this
but oftentimes you just want to like
you know invoke some external system
or a substring function or whatever
that's not available
as part of the standard commands some
small little thing that can be done like
in a one liner or in a three liner
and actually writing a whole command and
compiling it and
putting it in a class path is already
way too much overhead for a lot of
people for doing that little thing
so now we have this so we introduced
this little command called java and
you can write scripting code it's
actually full-blown java code
but you know certainly in red you can
write that java you know
code right directly in line there and
and when the morph line gets compiled
that thing gets compiled into a java
class and into java by code and executed
so
you can you know write some quick and
dirty stuff
or try things out that way pretty
conveniently
i would not recommend like writing a 500
line
java transformation in this way you know
so like there's a lot
there's some abuse threshold somewhere
so i would say like you know if it's if
it's more than five lines
of java code it's probably better to
write your own
command command you know and unit test
it and so forth
but if it's a if it's like three lines
of code
then you know this is an effective way
of getting
the job done i suppose
it's compiled it's compiled into at on
startup when that
configuration file gets loaded up it
just
literally just writes you know a big
string
that contains like you usually would
write in a java
program and then it compiles that thing
in memory using the java compiler
into a class and loads that class at
runtime
and then runs it and so it gets cheated
by you know
by the java runtime the way any other
class gets treated so
and of course that happens only the
compilation happens only once on startup
of the program and then you can run that
command the gazillion of
times you know and it's calling that
calling this command then it's just a
one uh java method invocation
it has that overhead which is for
practical
purposes you know like faster than you
actually needed
um here's a bunch of other commands that
are
currently already implemented in
shipping say i know
we have you know i mentioned this
integration with solar and
log file analysis single records
multi-record csv files regularly
based pattern regular expression based
pattern matching and extraction
a lot of things i already mentioned like
avro and
excel and so forth we also integrate
with the apache teacup parser library
apache tikka is a library of like you
know hundreds of
parsers for things that you don't want
to write
nobody wants to write like microsoft
word parsing pdf parsing you know like
you know whatever jpeg extracting the
metadata from jpeg files about you know
how many pixels does that photo have and
you know
lord knows what you know stuff that you
don't want to write you know like and so
we just integrate with that library and
so there's like
hundreds of you know file formats that
we we kind of get for free you know
plus then there is this also from
apachetica we inherit this
nifty facility for detecting by looking
at the first couple of bytes
of some content what is actually the
type and what's the
what's the file type what's the what's
the content type
of that byte stream and then you can
react in your commands you can react to
that you can say like
if it's a application slash pdf
then do da and if it's csv
then do blah blah blah and so forth so
yeah there's a little if command
you know and things like that so you can
react to whatever the
data format is and treat it in
in appropriate ways
i mentioned that scripting support the
java language
there's you can add things to a field
and
set fields and you know have assignments
and comparisons and like
you know it's so like the basic the
basic elements you know of like
uh some uh transformation
you know configuration language um if
then else
there's a there's a facility that people
use a lot called
try rules it's a little rule engine and
basically
the way that that's being used for
systems that need to
cope with multiple different data
formats say like
a log file where records aren't actually
just in one format
but for whatever reason they come in
like five different formats they're
all slightly different they're kind of
like the same but then they're also
different
and so you need to parse them properly
and deal with them in some
you know in some you know coherent way
and this trial rules command
allows you to do that to try different
matching
matchings and then if things match and
do this and if it doesn't match then try
the other thing and match that
and if it doesn't match and try
something else and so forth
it also integrates with some metric
matrix library from yammer
so every command it's in in production
like
if you have these systems running and
you know they run 24x7 it's important to
get some insight into like where the
time is spent and
how many errors do you have you know and
what's this thing actually doing in
production
and getting operational visibility into
what
uh how the system actually does you know
and
so we every command has can access
you know these metrics library so you
get timers and counters and
you know and meters and histograms and
whatnot and
so all of that can get published you
know to gangly or whatever monitoring
system you have or to jmx and things
like this
so inherit this and then it's got this
um
you know deep unpacking or
you know on nesting of like nested data
formats that
i already hinted at
i also hinted at already the plugin
infrastructure
there's two classes you know that to
implement it's very easy
you don't even need to provide like some
configuration file that describes you
know like
you know you know what the names of
these of these commands are or something
like this you just put it in a class
path and that's it
so here's an example that uses a command
called grok
that a lot of people use for log file
processing
and we adopted that from the logstest
project which has a very similar
physical facility
and so it basically allows you to
specify regular expressions in a little
bit more a scalable way
than than usual by
saying that we can define a library of
regular expressions in a file
or even inline here and give each
regular expression a name
and then we can compose regular
expressions by like stringing together
these names
rather than like these humongous
expressions you know and humongous in
another humongous
expression so that you can build up
complicated regular expressions that are
so tractable
and here's one that parses a syslog
file first it's being run through the
readline command which basically spits
out a record with
one line at a time and then it's run
through that grok command and it looks
into that dictionary which is like a
configuration file that you can provide
and then it says match the field called
message
try and match it against that expression
this grog
expression that basically plucks out
various substrings you know say like the
the process id or the
timestamp and things like that and so
you don't actually
write your regular expression literally
in there but you just
refer to say like a timestamp name
and under the covers the timestamp is
actually a real expression
but once you've defined that and it is
actually already defined for you
then you don't actually need to invent
that regular expression and unit test it
and so forth
and so we have this long library of
regular expressions that we adopted from
the logstash
project it's got hundreds of regular
expressions for common things
like timestamps and host names and
emails and you know whatnot
so you can just use them and you don't
actually have to debug them or write
them yourself and you should refer to
them
by name of course you can extend it with
your own
you know dictionary files you know if
that's what you do
but this comes in really handy i would
say this is the
by far the most commonly used command in
our
experience at least you know for
cloudera search
there's other things that you could do
that we have not done but you know like
that you know would be very interesting
to do
and quite conceivable which is like to
you know join
you know records as they flow through
the system with external data sources so
you like you know
look up tables or relational databases
or hbase you know
or you know annotated you know records
you know with
you know say like you know the two guip
lookups you know or pluck out you know
you know other kinds of informations do
dns lookups you know or
uh maintain streaming analytics over
time windows over sliding windows
you know on on the records that flow
through the system
you know things like that things like
that so
things that remind us that if you look
at it it's kind of like a stream
processing system
it's a stream processing system without
you know the server it's just the
embedded piece of it you know if you
like
so you could plug this into storm it's
not a replacement for storm
but you could write you know a storm
plug-in that runs a morph line and as
part of that
to you know does stream processing in
this similar way that
we provide a plug-in for flume that runs
a morph line as part of flume things
like that
so
i'm going to talk a little bit about
like how we use these
things in cloudera search to select
illustrate
a little bit about you know a little the
applicability of morph lines in that
context
so um you know search research is
basically
something that fits into the hadoop
ecosystem uh since we integrated
you know solar with cdh and with hadoop
and so it's basically the idea that you
have this giant
storage system hdfs and you already have
all of your data in there and
increasingly more and more applications
running on it and you also want to
search on it
but you don't want to do it in some yet
another silo
but on the very same storage system that
you already have you know and so it's
integrated you know with like the same
management infrastructure
same failover and availability that of
you know h.htfs has and so forth and so
forth and so forth
um but at the core of it really it's
like
an integration of uh cdh with um
apache solar and i already showed that
picture but we're gonna dive a little
bit more in detail in how that
how more flats are being used here just
a reminder we have
flume flows real time ingestion flows
going into search servers we have hbase
uh
interrupted and deletes crud
transactions happening
and and we maintain secondary indexes on
uh on the on that data in solar so that
you can search over your hbase data
we also have mapreduce facilities for
running mapreduce jobs that index
giants try and try and a heaps of
information
offline and then load them up into solar
and each of those demands
etl using and we we do that using
morselines
now for flume the way flume works is
that
very often people use it to ingest log
files you can use it for other stuff too
for any kind of binary data but most
most often people use it for log files
and so flume is really a graph of
processing elements
distributed processing elements that you
know
ship data from some source system into
a destination system most commonly
that's hdfs but can also be
solar or any other any other system
and we provide um
an integration point called the morph
line solar sync
which is the flume has this notion of
sinks which is
which are kind of like plug it's a
plug-in mechanism for flume
to take some data along that flow and
then do something with it and
load it up into some system there's for
example an hdfs
sync so if data comes in it dumps it
into hdfs files and that's the most
common
use for it but now we also have a solar
sync
a motion and solar sync and it you know
dumps the data into solar except for
dumping a raw data into solar isn't very
useful
so we run a morph line over it and then
you know run that morph line
and the last command is load solar but
if you strike out that last command
you could load it up into hbase or you
can load it up into you know whatever
you know
and so we have that integration with
with flume
and that has been upstreamed and it's
shipping as part of apache flume
1 4.
inside of cloudera manager this is this
preparatory enterprise
management tool the cloudera ships and
that provides a lot of its
revenue we have like gui tools you know
for
configuring and managing and monitoring
all of that stuff
so that's not part of so like the opeo
open source
offering all the management tools are
like
proprietary you know but the functioning
system is all open
it's all open source
so for how does it work with batch with
mapreduce so
the overall idea is you have these hdfs
files
you have a tool that selects you know
whatever files are interesting
to be indexed or to be loaded into the
etl tool
and then we run it through a morph line
as part of
the mapper and produce some output index
charts
and those charts are then loaded up into
solar
using a final go live step
and the way we package this up is using
the so-called mapreduce inductor tool
it takes a configuration file this morph
configuration file
uh just a text file and it runs it
on every task of every every mapper
on on that cluster and extracts you know
and transforms and does whatever it has
to do
and then the output of that goes into
reducers
which then you know combine the
information and select
for example eliminate you know duplicate
you know
of the very same piece of information
and then
build solar indexes which are then
loaded up into
into into solar and again if you strike
out that load solar piece of it
you have a mapreduce you know etl
processing system that just as part of
your mappers you know runs morph line
and
does whatever he wants to do so you can
use it for other things as well
how does it work for hbase well
we we use morph lines for near real-time
indexing
hbase has a facility to allow for
replication of
an hbase cluster to a slave cluster
for like say like you know backup or for
you know high availability
you know things like that and
the way we work this is that we plug
ourselves into the replication mechanism
and essentially listening on the
transaction log
we get every transaction that happens in
hbase and we're listening on that log
because we are a fake replication target
we're a
fake replication slave we pretend to be
like a
hbase cluster but we're not we're we're
an indexer really you know
but we receive all the updates and uh
and then you know run those run
every record or every cell through a
morph line
and um and the object goes into solar
so that's the way we build secondary
indexes
on hbase in a way that is
does not impact the production
readiness of of existing
applications that that are already very
much
rely on the hbase and do want to make
sure
that any kind of instability or
performance issue with solar does not
impact
their reads and rights into hbase
by hooking ourselves into this slave
mechanism
basically we get dimensional consistency
we don't get like
immediate consistency but on the other
hand you know like
even if solo goes down or if there's an
issue it's not going to impact the hbase
primary cluster and the applications
and the latency of these applications
and we did that work
in conjunction with a company called ng
data
and so the result of it is this lilly h
based indexer that
runs a morseline to do
etl and feed search indexes
and so when you put all this stuff
together that i mentioned
you get a little bit more of a messy
picture of all these elements in there
you know where where h base and flume
plays a role and solar plays a role in
hdfs and so forth and so forth
the idea is not to confuse you or
with like that messy picture but it's
sort of like to drive home the point
that there's
an awful lot of paths in that system
where you need to do an etl
and that was the main point that we try
to address with morph lines which is
that
we need this thing in all sorts of
different places so we better make it
embeddable and reusable so that we don't
have to do this any number of
any number of times you know yeah
so what are we going to do next the
hbase piece isn't actually
completely finished yet no more work to
be done
uh there and then morph lines will also
be integrated into
apache crunch which other hadoop
processing framework high-level
processing uh framework and
we're also thinking about commands for
stream analytics
that allow you know what
previously was not possible into which
is to do sub-second you know
some second latency stream analysis and
you know interactive dashboardings and
things like that
so um to conclusion to wrap it up
that all that stuff is already is
shipping as part of the
cloudera development kit for developers
and you can
pick it up there or contribute there and
uh there's a mailing list you know
for people who are interacting if you're
interested and there's also
a pre-packaged version of it that ships
with cloud air search
for for those kind of applications if
you want to try it out
maybe the easiest way is to download the
quickstart vm
the uh cdh cloudera
cloudera cdh quickstart vm which
contains the
the whole enchilada but among them also
morph lines
so it's an easy way for you to set up a
system and
try out say like map you do is indexing
with morph lines or
blue indexing with more lines and things
like that
you